euh alors euh donc je suis très heureux
si vous le voulez bien d'accueillir en
votre nom Jean-Jacques ayagon euh il y a
beaucoup de raisons je vais essayer d'en
dire quelques-unes très rapidement la
première il ne vous aura pas échappé
c'est que Jean-Jacques hayagon est le
cousin de Jean
Lassalle euh ils sont tous les deux de
la vallée d'Aspe dans les Pyrénées et
euh leur itinéraires sont au fond
extrêmement symétriques en tout cas dans
l'expression artistique qui caractérise
l'un et
l'autre et donc c'est le tous les deux
viennent de la de la Grande et Petite
par le nombre des habitants Vallet
d'Aspe là-haut au-dessus de doloron
Sainte-Marie dans les Pyrénées je suis
très heureux que Jean-Jacques ayagon
soit là c'est quelqu'un pour qui j'ai
une grande
estime
et qui joue dans notre vie
intellectuelle et culturelle un rôle
tout à fait éminent en raison des
responsabilités qui ont été les
siennes dans le courant de sa
vie à la fois de de haut responsa de la
culture et d'homme politique
français au fond c'est une vie que je
décris en quatre
étapes Jean-Jacques ayagon a
été
un un homme qui s'est investi dans
l'histoire et dans l'histoire de l'art
en
particulier je suis très heureux qu'il
soit avec nous pour réfléchir à ce
que peut-être ou de devrait être le
ministère de la Culture il a fait son
DEA sur violer le duc et l'enseignement
de l'architect ecture euh alors violet
le duuc comme vous savez a une œuvre
controversée mais ça n'est pas
l'essentiel du sujet en tout cas ceux
qui connaissent le château de poau ont
une idée comment dirais-je riche
complexe de des interventions de l'école
de violet l duuc parce que c'est pas
violet l duuc lui-même qui est intervenu
sur le château de Henri I mais c'est son
école c'était un sourire deuxè étape euh
il est d'abord professeur et puis il est
professeur à aigleton en corz et quand
on est à agleton et à Tul on croise des
routes illustres et il croise une route
illustre qui est celle au fond de
Jacques Chirac et Jacques Chirac
l'appelle auprès de lui à la mairie de
Paris euh dans diverses responsabilités
culturelles et euh l'une de ces
responsabilités tout à fait éminentes
sera la présidence de beauour euh et
donc il il occupera cette très éminente
fonction au moment même où euh au fond
le le l'histoire de cette œuvre tout à
fait exceptionnel va prendre un tournant
décisif euh ensuite il est ministre de
la Culture
euh et euh c'est un rôle dans lequel il
est reconnu je crois par euh un grand
nombre de gens alors ça l'empêche pas
d'avoir des euh relations euh complexes
avec le monde de la culture il y a pas
le monde le plus aisé qu'on puisse
trouver le monde de l'éducation
nationale non plus euh comme comme s'en
rendre compte euh les ministres actuels
euh après quoi il occupera une
responsabilité très éminente euh
puisqu'il sera le patron du Musée
national de Versailles euh pendant 5
années c'est ça Jean-Jacques pendant 5
années il ne sera pas renouvelé au terme
de ces 5 années ce qui
donnera ce qui fera naître beaucoup de
discussions dans le monde de la culture
ce qui prouve aussi qu'elle était
l'importance du rôle qu'il jouait et il
va exercer ensuite des
fonctions auprès de ce très grand
collectionneur qui est François Pinot et
des collections qui sont les en et tout
récemment il vient d'être élu président
du musée des artes décoratifs ce qui est
là encore un jalon quand vous avez fait
beauobourg Versailles et le musée des
des arts
décoratif le moins qu'on en puisse dire
est que vous avez marqué de votre
empreinte la vie culturelle du temps
Jean-Jacques ayagon a choisi et c'est un
une preuve de liberté d'esprit il a
choisi de traiter de la question de
savoir si euh il faut s'il faudrait et
quel rôle devrait jouer euh le ministère
de la culture comme vous savez il y a
bien des pays où il y a pas de ministère
de la Culture et c'est au fond en France
l'héritage de merau qui avec le
caractère légendaire de de l'homme
légendaire euh
fascinant
euh rigolo à certains égards qui a
marqué de son
empreinte l'action culturelle du pays
sous la forme d'un ministère de la
Culture qui est beaucoup plus que
l'ancien ministère des beauard puisque
c'est ainsi que autrefois on concevait
l'action publique autour de la culture
je suis donc très heureux que
Jean-Jacques ayagon soit là très heureux
aussi de
des échanges que très généreusement de
sa part nous avons
depuis plusieurs mois et même un peu
plus parce que c'est quelqu'un dont je
suis persuadé qu'il peut et va apporter
beaucoup à notre vie publique pas
seulement sur le thème de la culture
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui a un large
spectre de vision de qui est à la fois
très pénétré par l'expérience
personnelle et par l'histoire de notre
pays et dont je suis sûr que nous
n'avons pas fini de cueillir les fruits
en tout cas je voudrais avec vos
applaudissements lui dire merci d'être
là monsieur le Président cher François
tout d'abord soyez remercié pour votre
invitation et pour l'accueil si
chaleureux que vous me réservez
ici je tiens avant d'aborder le sujet
que nous propos on d'examiner ce soir à
vous dire ma vraiment ma très très vive
estime personnelle et ma conviction
totale à l'égard de votre engagement et
de votre action j'aimerais qu'au cours
des prochaines années au cours des
prochaines décennies la vie publique de
notre pays en soit très profondément
marqué et qu'ainsi un renouveau
puisse profondément sceller le destin de
notre de notre de notre pays vous avez
eu la bonté de rappeler quelques
éléments de ma biographie j'étais en
train de me dire que finalement après
Versailles et les arts décoratifs au
tuilerie il me restait plus qu'à aller à
la bille de Saint-Denis pour y trouver
pour y trouver un repos enfin bien
mérité mais j'espère y arriver le le
plus le plus tard possible
alors nousous posons ce soir la question
de savoir s'il faut un ministère de la
Culture je crois qu'il faut que nous
sachions les uns et les autres aborder
cette cette question avec beaucoup de
franchis et en refusant des effets de
rhthorique trop trop facile il y a
quelques années c'était en 2008 à la fin
de l'année 2008 je rentrais en France à
ce moment-là de Venise où j'avais
installé la la la Fondation Pino j'étais
président du château de versaill et un
journaliste du Monde Harry Belet mér
m'interrogait sur la situation du
ministère de la Culture et sur son
avenir et je crois que c'est un peu par
provocation que je lui ai dit ce dont il
s'est naturellement fait très rapidement
l'écho qu'on pourrait peut-être se
passer d'un ministère de la Culture
tant ce ministère semblait à ce
moment-là en voie de déconsidération et
en tout cas incapable de mettre en œuvre
de façon visible et de façon
convaincante une action une action
efficace je tenais aussi comme vous
l'avez fait François rappeler que qu'il
ne fallait pas oublier qu'il y avait eu
des poties multiculturel de l'État avant
l'existence d'un ministère de la
Culture le ministère de la Culture a été
créé non pas comme on l'entend parfois
par André Merot mais pour André merau en
1959 or l'État en France la République
notamment et même les régimes qui
avaient précédé la République avaient
déjà mis en œuvre des actions de
politique culturelle et parfois des
actions de politique culturelle
extrêmement efficaces qu'on songe à ce
qu' a été l'action y compris
institutionnel de la 3e et de la 4e
République le réseau des des musées des
bibliothèque tel que nous le connaissons
aujourd'hui même s'il a été
considérablement amélioré est en grande
partie issu de cet engagement des des
républiques antérieures à la 5e
République je faisais aussi remarquer
que finalement par un paradoxe
extraordinaire on pour avoir un
ministère de la Culture sans bénéfice de
politique culturelle et en sens
contraire finalement considérer que
l'État et les autres collectivités
publiques qu'il ne faut pas oubliier les
collectivités locales pouvaient mettre
en œuvre des politiques culturelles sans
qu'il y ait un ministère de la Culture
alors ce débat vous le savez c'est très
rapidement enraciné on le voit
régulièrement ressurgir notamment au
moment des grandes échéances politiques
nationales les élection présidentiell
qui sont le plus formidable ring qu'on
puisse imaginer pour débattre de des
idées de façon générale et peut-être
occasionnellement de cette idée de façon
plus
particulière ce débat c'est d'une
certaine façon au cours des dernières
années purifiées pendant longtemps la
contestation d'un de l'existence d'un
ministère de la culture était
essentiellement porté par ce qu'on
pourrait qualifier d'ultralibéraux qui
pensit que les ressorts spontanés de la
société pouvaient finalement permettre
l'épanouissement d'une vie culturelle
satisfaisante sans que l'État s'enmêle
et qu'il était même d'ailleurs c'est le
point de vue de certains analystes comme
Marc fumareli qu'il était même
inopportun que l'État s'en occupe sous
peine de voir apparaître des formes de
culture d'État lors ces points de vue
qu'on qualifiera mais je suis bien
conscient du fait que cette façon un peu
caricaturale d'ultralibéraux se sont un
peu euh assoupi mais néanmoins euh le
ministère de la Culture ayant
paradoxalement là aussi à force
d'optimisme et d'abondance de la
promesse suscitaé euh trop d'attentes et
donc trop de déception par manque de
réalisation de ces attentes ce ministère
a fini par apparaître parfois comme un
ministère incapable d'avoir prise sur la
réalité avant d'aller plus loin dans
l'analyse de ce phénomène j'observe
simplement que c'est peut-être une
analyse qui peut concerner l'état tout
entier dans sa forme actuelle on voit
bien que l'État se porte sur beaucoup de
fronts et parfois de façon très très
émotive on a beaucoup là aussi les
observateurs souligné le caractère
parfois éminemment et excessivement
émotif de
l'intervention des ministres sur tel ou
tel
front de l'actualité de la société y
compris parfois sur des euh situation
qui relève du fait euh du fait diviver
ce sont trop souvent proposés euh de
mettre fin à des situations que euh le
gouvernement ou les ministres
stigmatisés euh ce sont trop souvent
proposé euh euh d'amplifier l'arsenal
des lois quand il s'agissait de réprimer
tel ou tel travers hein pour qu'ensuite
les faits ayant euh finalement la peau
beaucoup plus dure qu'on pouvait
l'imaginer sans susciter ensuite une
profonde déception de la part des des
citoyensz chers amis entre un état muet
qui se serait totalement dissipé et un
état trop prolixe trop bavard la
distance finit souvent par être
extrêmement faible parce que dans les
deux cas qu'il soit excessivement bavard
ou excessivement silencieux il finit par
devenir inaudible en tout cas par ne
plus être écouté par les citoyens
toujours est-il que pour revenir au
ministère de la Culture si on analyse un
peu le paradoxe de sa
situation on se rend compte que c'est un
ministère dont la parole est tout
particulièrement omniprésente encore que
j'observe qu'au cours des derniers mois
cette parole soit un peu tempérée et ne
se porte plus
systématiquement sur des déclaration
incessante sur toute et rien il y a un
an ou un an et demi il m'arrivait
parfois de me moquer de mes successeur
au ministère de la Culture en dis en
soulignant qu'il passaient leur journée
à se féliciter d'eux à féliciter telle
ou telle personne à regretter que à
stigmatiser annoncer que considérant par
exemple que les nomination n'étaient
plus des actes de gouvernement profond
mais uniquement des actes des occasions
de communique
cette trop répandue maladie de la
politique qui voudrait tout réduire à
l'instant à l'instant à l'instantanéité
en perdant de vue la nécessité de
labourer en profondeur et de cultiver
les choses pour pour l'avenir donc une
parole omniprésente qui se mesure par
exemple par l'abondance des communiqués
de presse dont ce ministère peut à
chaque minute quasiment
assiéger l'Agence France Presse dont
elle attend naturellement un relais
efficace de sa parole et dans le même
temps on a parfois l'impression que
cette abondance de la parole
s'accompagne d'une prise finalement
assez faible sur la réalité des choses
cette prise affaiblie sur la réalité des
choses tient au fait que depuis
1959 et depuis les années 80 qui ont été
marqué par la puissance de la
personnalité d'un ministre comme Jack
Lang qui a bénéficié de deux grands
atouts tout d'abord l'atout de la durée
hein il aura été ministre de la Culture
et d'ailleurs occasionnellement
également de l'éducation nationale
pendant de fois 2 x 5 ans et bénéficier
également d'une manne budgétaire
extraordinaire au budget de 1982 qui
brusquement
a doublé sa capacité d'intervention donc
le souvenir de cette période faisant on
se rend compte qu'aujourd'hui ce notre
notre ministère de la culture n'a pas
insuffisamment n'a pas suffisamment
pardonnez-moi prise en compte un certain
nombre de modification radicale du
paysage par rapport à cette époque par
exemple prise en compte le fait que à
côté de son
action l'action des collectifs é locale
est devenu dans certains
cas majeur et parfois même
prépondérante pendant longtemps on
aurait pu imaginer le ministère de la
culture comme sorte comme une sorte
d'opérateur public universel et unique
alors que patiemment les collectivités
locales dans leur différents degrés
d'organisation les communes les
communautés de communes les
départements les régions assumer des
responsabilités de plus en plus larges
ou bien dans le cadre de lois de
décentralisation ou bien Motu Proprio
parce qu'elle décidait sans aucune
obligation de le faire de mettre en
œuvre des des projets des politique
culturelle
significative également autre élément
qu'on a insuffisamment prise en compte
c'est
euh le caractère désormais prépondérant
agissant de la mise à disposition des
gens de façon générale des citoyens de
tous ceux qui vivent dans notre pays et
de ceux qui s'intéressent à notre
culture dans le monde on a
insuffisamment pris en compte le poids
l'importance de ce qu'on appelle
les les les industries culturelles et
donc le poids de la production de la
production culturelle alors le fait
qu'il existe des industries culturelles
n'est pas une nouveauté l'édition est
une réalité ancienne même si elle est
aujourd'hui parfois dans ses formes
traditionnelles menacé mais on sait à
quel point la production de musique a
été
révolutionnée en tout cas le contact
avec la musique ont été révolutionnés
par toutes les
technologies de l'information de la
communication de la production sonore et
à quel point aujourd'hui plus qu'il y a
50 ans qu'il y a 40 ans
les uns et les autres nous pouvons
accéder à une offre musicale importante
à une offre musicale large ça vaut
également pour l'offre cinématographique
et ça vaut pour toutes les formes
d'expression artistiques qui sont liées
de façon plus délibéré aux technologies
de l'information et de la communication
alors la numérisation des œuvres la
capacité de les compacter dans des
formats extrêmement réduits de les
diffuser de façon extrêmement rapide ont
révolutionné ont métamorphosé de façon
radicale le mode les modalités de
relation que nous pouvons avoir les uns
et les autres avec tout ce qui
constitue la
culture songeer il m'est arrivé
récemment d'en parler avec des
bibliothèques songeer ce quiétait le
travail de recherche en bibliothèque on
se déplaçait vers une bibliothèque on
allait vers les fichiers qui
étaient hein fermé dans des tiroirs on
tirait ces tiroirs on consultait des
fiches on notait sur une feuille de
papier la référence du livre qu'on
voulait consulter on le
portait au point de livraison des
ouvrages un magazinier se porter dans
les magasins vous remontez
éventuellement l'ouvrage si n'était pas
déjà en prêt parce que personne selon
personne ne pouvait préjuger à l'instant
à l'instant même il se passait dans les
grandes bibliothèques parfois beaucoup
de temps avant que l'ouvrage ne remonte
des profondeurs des réserves souvent la
page qui vous intéressait avait été
altérée parce que déchiré ou arraché par
un chercheur indélicat qui voulait
s'éviter le travail de la de la de la
recopier ou de la
synthétiser très rapidement votre
lecture vous portez vers un autre titre
et il fallait recommencer naturellement
les mêmes opérations tout cela était
extrêmement fastidieux tout sous était
extrêmement lent tout ça était
extrêmement délocalisé aujourd'hui il
est évident que nous accédons les uns et
les autres a une masse immense de
références d'information d'images
d'œuvres et qu'il y a là le ferement
d'une révolution d'une véritable
révolution culturelle autre élément qui
a naturellement changé le paysage de
façon assez radicale c'est l'émergence
désormais dans le champ de l'initiative
culturelle d'acteurs d'acteurs privés de
fondation de particuliers de
collectionneurs du marché de le l'art
qui devient s'agissant de la
reconnaissance des artistes une instance
de tout premier ordre vous le savez
s'agissant de la reconnaissance des
œuvres et des artistes on a longtemps
distingué finalement trois instances de
consécration la critique l'institution
et le marché pendant longtemps c'est la
critique au début du 20e siècle qui a
été l'instance pondérante celle qui
faisait l'opinion à l'égard du public
qu'on a vu au 20e siècle au milieu du
20e siècle l'institution s'affirmé comme
la référence déterminante c'est l'époque
des grandes institutions à l'étranger
que sont le MoMA ou en France le Centre
Pompidou Musée national d'art moderne
aujourd'hui on le voit bien un marché
mondialisé de l'art s'est installé sur
la scène internationale fait et dé fait
les réputations
porte les côtes des artistes à des
niveaux souvent impressionnants si ce
n'est d'ailleurs extravagant et tout
cela change considérablement la donne et
modifie la relation que le public peut
avoir avec les œuvres tout cela renvoie
la puissance publique la la question de
sa possibilité d'agir et des modalités
de son de son action également autre
observation concernant le ministère de
la Culture et c'est une constatation qui
me préoccupe beaucoup et je pense
qu'elle préoccupe également beaucoup
François baayrou c'est que dans notre
pays on a établi une distinction
beaucoup trop large entre la culture ce
qu'on appelle la culture d'un côté et le
savoir de
l'autre l'existence d'un ministère de la
Culture a eu beaucoup d'avantages je
n'en dis conviens pas mais également
convénient finalement d'établir d'un
côté un domaine qu'on pourrait qualifier
du domaine des Beaux Arts et des belles
lettres vieille dénomination d'ailleurs
de ce ministère et d'un autre côté un
champ du savoir de la connaissance de
l'éducation de l'enseignement qui
paradoxalement lui est devenu étranger
ou plus exactement les deux étant se
sentant ou se ressentant comme étranger
l'un à l'autre comme si l'histoire la
géographie les sciences naturelles les
sciences de la Terre l'arithmétique les
mathématiques l'apprentissage d'une
langue de plusieurs langues de la
littérature l'acquisition d'une maîtrise
à l'égard du parler ne constituait pas
profondément des actes de culture en
étant euh au début de ma vie
professionnelle professeur d'histoire et
de géographie j'ai eu le sentiment
d'exercer un métier culturel quand je
suis je suis arrivé dans l'emprise du
ministère de la Culture je me suis rendu
compte qu'on qu'on ne considérait pas
que c'était de la culture la culture
c'était uniquement le théâtre la musique
les arts plastiques l'architecture donc
la production d'œuvres la production
d'objets culturel il y a là sans doute
une une un travers de l'esprit français
en tout cas ce travers a très très
profondément marqué l'histoire du
ministère de la Culture et aujourd'hui à
mon avis ampute un peu
la profondeur et l'enracinement de son
action autre réalité que ce ministère
n'a pas suffisamment prise en compte ce
sont tous les phénomènes de la
mondialisation on l'a évoqué à propos du
marché de l'art on le constate chaque
jour aujourd'hui s'agissant des régimes
de protection des droits des créateurs
ou de leurs ayant droits dans un marché
de l'information et de la communication
totalement mondialisé
euh à ce phénomène de la prise en compte
nécessaire de la mondialisation s'ajoute
et c'est une réalité qui m'est
extrêmement cher la nécessité de prendre
en compte ce que le ministère de la
Culture a insuffisamment fait bien qu'il
s'y porte bien qu'il se porte
régulièrement sur ce front la
nécessité dans un continent européen
marqué par la diversité de ces cultures
et pourtant la profonde unité euh de ces
références culturelles la nécessité
finalement de s'interroger et de
s'interroger de façon décisive de façon
profonde sur la nécessité de construire
une politique culturelle européenne
alors le sujet est très délicat parce
que les traités européens ont fait de la
culture un domaine subsidiaire de
responsabilité des États non mis en
œuvre des programmes culturel
qu'extrêmement marginaux comme le
programme par exemple des capitales
culturels européenne c'est intéressant
mais c'est insuffisant parce que si
l'Europe est bien caractérisée par un
trait de
caractère c'est que tous les pays qui la
composent malgré la diversité des
langues qu'il pratique et cette
diversité est une
richesse que cette construction est
néanmoins marquée par une très très
profonde unité de ces références
culturelles qui puisent dans des
héritages culturel commun qu'on retrouve
dans l'antiquité romaine dans
l'Antiquité grecque dans naturellement
le christianisme qui a été l'un des
fédérateurs de l'union de de de de la
personnalité européenne dans la conquête
de l'esprit critique ensuite dans ce
qu'on a appelait l'héritage des lumières
dans tout ce qui a procédé de la
révolution industrielle on voit bien
qu'il y a là une singularité culturelle
qui n'a pas été assumé de façon
suffisante par la construction
européenne et par l'ambition de chacun
des pays qui compose l'Union européenne
donc on le voit un paysage profondément
changé parce que le monde a changé parce
que l'Europe cette Europe qui est hélas
aujourd'hui dans une très mauvaise passe
dans beaucoup de pays de l'Union
européenne on le voit en Italie euh
euh donc mondial tion nécessité de
prendre en compte la construction
européenne de prendre en compte l'impact
des technologies de l'information et de
la communication l'émergence de nouveaux
acteurs tout cela s'est produit sans que
le ministère de la Culture finalement ne
reconsidère suffisamment ses objectifs
ses méthodes et sa façon de présenter
son action à l'opinion publique au
citoyens et en cela je reviens sur ce
point finalement son attitude n'a rien
de singulier dans le paysage de l'action
de l'État dans le paysage de l'action
gouvernementale c'est finalement un
syndrome ou un symptôme qui pourrait
caractériser la situation de beaucoup de
ministères alors je me suis souvent
poser la question de savoir que faire
alors il est évident que lorsque je
m'interrogeais sur la nécessité d'un
ministre d'un ministère de la Culture je
poussais le bouchon de la provocation
très loin il est évident et je tiens à
vous à répondre clairement sur ce point
aussitôt je crois que l'action
culturelle de l'État est nécessaire de
la même façon que je pense que l'action
culturelle de toutes les collectivités
publiques est nécessaire parce que ces
collectivités ont une responsabilité
immense à l'égard de l'épanouissement de
la dignité des citoyens qu'elles ont une
responsabilité immense à
l'égard du de du rayonnement culturel de
notre pays
parce qu'elles ont également en charge
ce principe sacré qui fond de l'action
publique dans notre pays le principe
d'égalité une action privée est parfois
extrêmement pertinente mais elle elle ne
se soucie pas par exemple de l'égalité
des territoire un jour me trouvant il y
a longtemps il y a plus de 20 ans à Los
Angeles 30 ans même je m je
m'interrogeais ou j'interrogeais mes mes
meses mes autres sur l'inexistence à
cette époque à Los Angeles d'un opéra
grande ville al d pourquoi n'y a-t-il
pas d'opéra et alors on m'a répondu que
il n'y avait pas d'opéra parce que
Madame Chandler n'aimait pas l'opéra
qu'elle n'aimait que la musique
symphonique la bienfaitrice de la
musique à Los Angeles cétait une dame
fortunée qui s'appelait Dorothé Dorothy
Chandler et donc Dorothy Chandler
n'aimant que la musique symphonique
avait construit ou fait construire une
grande salle pour la musique symphonique
une salle philarmonique mais l'opéra ça
lui cassait les pieds donc il n'y avait
pas d'opéra dans la ville il est évident
que l'action publique a d'autres
critères d'autres réflexes qu'elle se
soucie d'une part d'une égalité ou en
tout cas d'une d'une cohérence de
l'offre culturel elle se préoccupe elle
se soucie que cette offre culturelle
soit aussi également que possible
réparti sur le territoire que tous les
citoyens également quelques soit leur
état quel que soit leur origine quelle
que soit leur conditions puissent y
céder en tout cas en avoir le désir dans
des conditions équivalents donc je pense
que l'action culturelle de l'État est
nécessaire et puisque nous avons pris
l'habitude là aussi c'est un une
profession de foi pragmatique puisque
nous avons pris
l'habitude de l'existence d'un ministère
de la Culture et bien que cette action
cette ambition publique soit servie par
un ministère qui aurait de façon
exclusive ou entre autres la charge des
de ce qu'on appelait à l'époque de mal
les affaires culturelles
cependant je crois qu'il serait
idéalement souhaitable de tendre vers un
jour l'existence d'un ministère de la
Culture large et non pas ancré sur un
champ trop étroit de responsabilité pour
moi un ministère de la Culture large
c'est un ministère qui embrasserait
l'éducation la culture les politiques en
faveur de la jeunesse et l'audiovisuel
public donc tout ce qui peut servir et
de servir de façon efficace au partage
de la culture l'éducation est le
principal espace d'acculturation
universellement
accessible certains jeunes ont la chance
d'avoir une famille cultivée dans
laquelle ils acquierrent des références
nombreuses solides critiques
distancé varié d'autres n'ont pas cette
chance c'est à l'école à leur offrir
cette possibilité à condition qu'on
considère que ce qui fait l'objet de
l'enseignement scolaire constitue aussi
un ferment de de culture j'ai pour ma
part une reconnaissance immense à
l'égard de ceux qui ont été mes maîtres
je me souviens très précisément de
certains professeurs de français par
exemple qui m'ont donné le goût de la
littérature qui nous familiariser avec
le théâtre classique en nous invitant à
jouer des des
des actes de de de Fèdre de britanicus
d'andromac des plideurs c'est la raison
pour laquelle il m'arrive encore
d'impressionner un auditoire trop facile
en récitant tel ou tel passage de l'une
ou l'autre de ces pièces nous récitions
en les mimant les horisons funèbres de
de Bossuet ou de bourdalou nous
plongions avec délies dans la
littérature des 18e et et 19e siècle et
on apprenait avec respect Victor Hugo
donc il y a là vraiment la preuve s'il
le fallait que l'école est vraiment
l'espace
d'acculturation le plus efficace le plus
universel avant même qu'on pose la
question qui ne vient qu'après des arts
des arts à l'école n'y aurait-il pas
d'art à l'école et je souhaiterait qu'il
y ait des arts à l'école mais n'y
aurait-il pas d'art à l'école que
l'école serait déjà un espace et le
meilleur espace possible
d'acculturation la deuxième question
qu'il faut se poser si on s'interroge
sur le sur l'avenir de ce ministère
c'est la question de sa capacité à à
repenser son sa relation avec les
collectivités locales je dois dire que
l'absence d'un énoncé clair des
programmes d'aménagement culturel du
territoire du ministère de la Culture
rend souvent les choix que ce ministère
peut faire extrêmement peu
compréhensible par les élus et par les
citoyens aujourd'hui quand on observe la
cartographie des équipements culturels
de notre pays on se rend compte que
c'est une cartographie qui s'est
sédimentarisée au fil des décennies mais
sans logique clairement énonçable dans
tel département vous aurez près d'une
dizaine de structures de théâtres
subventionné centres dramatiques
nationaux scènes national
je pense par exemple au Département de
la scène maritime et dans d'autres
départements rien du tout ben dans un
département il y aura eu toute une toute
une cascade d'élus d'élus influents il y
aura eu il y aura eu gen le canué il y
aura eu rufnart il y aura eu Fabius et
quelques autres et puis donc une
accumulation d'initiatives dans d'autres
les élus auront été moins influents ou
moins pressants ou moins déterminés et
la danse cé des équipements culturels
soutenus par l'État et beaucoup beaucoup
moindre en tout cas je crois qu'il faut
aujourd'hui repenser la question de
l'interaction entre l'État et les
collectivités locales et j'observe
d'ailleurs que si c'est le cas dans le
domaine de la culture c'est le cas
également dans d'autres domaines où
l'État engage sa responsabilité et son
action dans le même cas d'ailleurs je
pense que le phénomène de la
déconcentration qui a conduit euh l'État
a suscité dans les régions une
ramification de ces services pourrai
être remise en cause je suis
paradoxalement favorable à la fois à la
décentralisation ou à une
décentralisation accrue et à une
reconcentration des moyens que l'État
affecterait à ses propres à ses propres
actions pour donner à cette action de
l'État plus de visibilité s'agissant de
la décentralisation on sait à quel point
les lois de décentralisation de 1982 de
2004 pour non citer quelquesunes ont été
déterminantes et ont servi
finalement la qualité de l'action
culturelle mise à la disposition du
public quand en 2002 donc dans le cadre
de la décentralisation de fire on a
confié au département les archives
départementales ou les services sans
trop de prêt des bibliothèques quand en
2004 on a confié au région l'Inventaire
général les richesses artistiques on
s'est rapidement rendu compte que ces
services finalement grâce au moyens que
les collectivités locales dans une
philosophie de proximité avait mobilisé
en leur faveur que ces services étaient
devenu beaucoup plus efficace que
lorsqu'il était dirigé de façon de façon
centralisée donc il y a là un véritable
chantier à ouvrir je crois également euh
qu'il y a une véritable nécessité pour
ce ministère s'il avait accompli ces
deux véritables révolutions d'arriver à
un énoncé clair de ses priorités de ses
choix et de ses actions un entassement
d'initiative ne fait pas vous le savez
François une politique une politique
c'est un point de vue c'est ce sont des
idées ce sont des convictions et il est
bon que la puissance publique les énonce
de la façon la plus claire de façon
indiquer aux citoyens où on se propose
de les accompagner ou on se propose dans
certains cas de les conduire trop
souvent nos concitoyens sont déconcertés
par le caractère possiblement
ératique des décisions et parfois
contradictoires des décisions qui sont
prises ils finissent par perdre de vue
que ces décisions doivent concourir à
l'émergence d'une politique d'une
politique globale c'est vrai dans le
domaine de la culture
c'est vrai également dans d'autres
domaines de l'action de l'État et enfin
je crois qu'il serait nécessaire de
réfléchir à l'utilisation beaucoup plus
efficace des
moyens qui sont mis à la disposition de
l'action publique culturelle à la faveur
d'un côté de l'émergence parfois de
nouvelles ressources vous souvenez
peut-être que j'ai été le promoteur de
la loi du 1er août 2003 sur le mcénat et
les fondations parce que j'estimais tout
simplement que le temps était venu dans
notre pays hein d'autoriser chaque
citoyen à disposer d'une part de son de
sa dette fiscale à l'égard de la
collectivité pour l'affecter à une
action d'intérêt général de son choix
d'où les réductions d'impôts mises en
place par cette loi au
bénéfice au bénéfice des actions de
mesénat mais également dans le même
temps outre l'émergence de nouvelles
recettes veiller à ce que les moyens
budgétaires mis à la disposition de
l'État soient utilisés de façon de façon
plus
efficace cette année le la ministre de
la Culture aurélie philippetti a assumé
je dois le dire avec beaucoup de courage
l'érosion à hauteur de 2 % des moyens de
son ministère alors certains ont crié au
scandale en disant que c'était un
mauvais ministre parce qu'un mauvais
ministre devait toujours pousser à
l'augmentation per permanent de ses
moyens budgétaires au contraire je
trouve qu'elle a fait preuve d'une
véritable vertu celle d'assumer le choix
de la rigueur qui devrait d'ailleurs
s'imposer de façon plus nette à toutes
les politiques de l'État alors
malgré ce assement ou cette légère
érosion cette économie appliquée à la
ressource de ce ministère je crois qu'il
faut quand même se souvenir des chiffres
concernés parce qu'il nous montre que
dans aucun pays d'Europe les états ne
mobilise autant de moyens pour leur
action culturelle l'addition des budgets
culture et des budgets
communication conduit à constater un
budget de 7,4 milliards d'euros c'est
beaucoup c'est beaucoup
d'argent le budget pr culture et soutien
à la presse c'est 3 millions c'est 3
Millard 550 millions d'euros le budget
de l'audiovisuel public s'élève à euh 3
millard830 millions d'euros je faisais
la traduction de cette somme en francs
pour montrer à quel point je vous ferai
l'économie des anciens francs mais en
tout cas euh
3illard830 millions d'euros c'est à peu
près 25 millions 25 milliards
pardonnez-moi 600 millions de francs
donc on voit bien qu'il y a là des
crédits substantiel euh qui hélas et
c'est un peu la faiblesse de ce ministre
missaire sont en début d'exercice
budgétaire quasi totalement préaffectés
par la simple reconduction des
engagements par la simple reconduction
des actions et donc malgré le caractère
extrêmement consistant de ces dotations
budgétaires on se rend compte que
finalement la marge d'initiative des
ministres est extrêmement faible je
crois qu'il faudrait oser dans une
véritable attitude de révision des
politiques publiques se poser la
question de la de la meilleure
efficacité de chaque euro dépensé il
m'est arrivé monsieur le Président mais
l'idée va vous paraître totalement folle
de souhaiter la le rétablissement du
paiement du paiement en numéraire parce
que je me dis que parfois si les gens se
rendaient compte des masses immenses
d'argent dont ils disposent ils auraient
plus de respect pour la dépense publique
imaginez le comptable public recevant
euh ces euh ces créanciers et comptant
euh ces liaces d'euros on verrait
l'accumulation immense de la dépense
publique la dématérialisation de
l'argent sa réduction à l'état de
signature sont sans doute l'une des
causes hein du Galot euh du Galot de la
dépense publique parce que tout cela
c'est totalement est devenu totalement
totalement abstrait alors je n'imagine
pas une seconde qu'on rétablirait euh
hein les paiements en numéraire mais euh
cette parabole en quelque sorte devrait
nous renvoyer les uns et les autres à
considérer la question de l'efficacité
de la dépense publique avec beaucoup
plus de beaucoup plus de pertinence et
beaucoup plus de respect et je sais
d'ailleurs que c'est un sujet qui vous
qui vous préoccupe alors comme je vous
le laissais entendre je pense que ces
objectifs de réforme sont inséparables
de la réforme générale des finalement de
l'État et de ses politiques elle nous
renvoie à la question euh de la
redéfinition d'un ordre de de peut-être
même de l'ordre constitutionnel et
politique général de la France de façon
à ce qu'un jour puisse émerger des
majorités d'un autre type que les
majorités d'aujourd'hui majorités
mécanique qui se livre au jeu incessant
de la contestation des points de vue de
la majorité en place même quand ces
points de vues sont les points de vuees
qui hier étaient défendus par une
majorité éteinte et qui est de devenu la
la minorité ce caractère mécanique
empêche finalement et le principal frein
à la réforme de l'État à la réforme de
son action parce qu'elle livre la France
un épuisant un épuisant jeu de va et
vien qui se réduit vraiment à qui se
réduit au choix entre le soutien sans
discernement ou l'opposition sans sans
nuance deuxème objectif général que
finalement auquel renvoie cette analyse
de la situation du ministère de la
culture c'est celle de la réforme de
l'État et de son organisation y compris
d'ailleurs dans son expression
ministérielle je crois la nécessité de
de de de portefeuille ministériel large
capable de concevoir des politiques qui
soient pas des politiques trop
sectoriell mais des politiques qui
embrassent l'intérêt général avec
d'ampleur plus de pertinence et plus
d'efficacité ça nous renvoie également à
la question cruciale de la réforme de
l'organisation
territoriale je suis toujours pour ma
part impressionné de constater que
l'Assemblée nationale constituante a dès
1789 et en
1790 réussi en quelques mois à modifier
à révolutionner totalement
l'organisation territoriale de la France
substituant au baillage au sénéchaussé
au pays d'État au pays d'élection au
gouvernerorat un ordre un ordre
territorial nouveau en suscitant la
création géniale des des département
génial pour l'époque des départements
soumettant même d'ailleurs
l'organisation ecclésiastique de la
France au même schéma avec un peu de
violence c'est vrai mais avec une
efficacité redoutable aujourd'hui
on va de petite réformes territorial en
petite réforme territorial donc il
faudrait penser de façon large la
question des communes la question des
départements la question des régions je
pense que chacun de ces degrés
d'organisation territoriale est
nécessaire et que la solution ce n'est
pas le gommage de l'une ou l'autre de
ces instances territoriales mais
vraiment la redéfinition de commune plus
vaste de départements viables parce
qu'un département dont la population est
trop effondrée est un département qui
n'a plus la capacité d'être une instance
de solidarité des régions également à la
fois ancré dans l'histoire ancré dans la
géographie et capable de mobiliser des
moyens significatifs pour mettre en
œuvre des politiques des politiques
raisonnable c'est la réforme générale
également de la gouvernance dans le
style
euh dans euh les méthodes euh et dans
l'énoncer euh des objectifs
c'est enfin la question de la gestion
des deniers publics des moyens que
l'impôt met la disposition de la de la
collectivité en tendant vers un
équilibre reconnu comme comme juste
entre ce que chaque individu qui
travaille peut consacrer à des actions
dont il est le libre dont il dont il don
dont il dispose à à son libre choix et
d'autre part la part de cette ressource
qui est affectée de façon tout aussi
légitime à l'action de la collectivité
et à l'expression de la
solidarité nationale et enfin je crois
que l'objectif général vers lequel nous
renvoie cette analyse ponctuelle de ce
microcosme qui est dans le fond le
ministère de la Culture n renvoie
également vers la question de la de la
construction européenne vers la question
de l'affir tion d'une nouvelle ambition
dans ce domaine dans un contexte
détestable où à force de de l'acheter
plusieurs générations de responsables
politiques quand il ne voulit pas
assumer leur responsabilité nationale
imputter finalement la construction
européenne la responsabilité les mots
qui pouvaient frapper notrees pays comme
il comme elle frappait également
d'autres pays on a trop tapé sur
l'Europe sur la bureaucratie européenne
sur la Commission européenne sur le
Parlement européen sur les institutions
européennes hein pour aujourd'hui ne pas
constater que ces critiques incessantes
et paradoxal alors que le processus de
construction européenne se poursuivait
que ces critiques incessantes avaient un
effet
délétaire dont on récolte aujourd'hui la
mer la mer
euh la M
récolte
je vais vous donner la parole pour le
dialogue qui fera 20 25 minutes avec
Jean-Jacques
ayagon je voudrais lui dire merci pour
une réflexion très euh comment dirais-je
enracinée dans une expérience je voudis
lui dire merci pour ce qu'il a dit euh
euh lorsqu'il s'approchait de la fin
sur ce qu'avait été l'œuvre géniale de
la Révolution et de Napoléon
après sur
l'organisation administrative et
politique du
pays comme quelques-uns d'entre vous le
savent j'ai un livre qui va sortir dans
quelques
jours ce chapitre est présent à
l'intérieur du livre exactement avec les
mêmes
référence
pourquoi parce que je pense qu'il est
impossible d'avoir un débat
politique sur un objet la puissance
publique l'État les collectivités
locales dont personne ne peut
comprendre l'architecture l'économie et
l'action mes amis savent que je suis
complètement obsédé par cette question
de la simplicité de l'organisation des
choses
euh c'est
incompréhensible je n'aurais jamais voté
la loi qui a été votée sans notre sans
notre assentiment hier sur les
cantons bisexuels là
euh sur
enfin
franchement euh n'est-ce pas j'ai été
président de conseil général 10 ans je
parle devant les élus de ma région Jean
Lassal Robert Rochefort qui sont là
Marielle s'excuse et elle a été obligée
de s'en aller elle devait être là
euh je voudrais qu'on m'explique la
différence qu'il y a entre l'action d'un
conseil général et d'un conseil régional
je voudrais qu'on me
l'explique parce que moi je n'ai jamais
compris la différence euh au fond
conseil général et conseil régional font
exactement la même chose sur des
échelles
différentes au fond ils ont tous les
deux la responsabilité d'une stratégie
de développement local et ils agissent
sur tous les boutons sur toutes les
touches disponibles pour la stratégie de
développement
local ici
favorise une
université nous il nous est arrivé de
construire une autoroute conseil général
c'est peut-être la seule de France mais
Dieu sait qu'elle a été utile on fait
des zones industrielles ou de
développement industriel on fait on fait
une politique
culturelle on fait la politique de la
lecture pour les uns et puis pour les
autres des politiques d'équipement de je
sais pas quoi de musées de c'est la même
chose alors vous avez deux sortes d'élus
dont au moins une catégorie est
absolument inconnue du citoyen les élus
je voudrais savoir qui connaî les élus
régionaux moi dans mon propre
département et il n'y en a que 17 je
suis
vaguement attentif à la politique je
suis pas sûr que je pourrais en citer la
moitié et même probablement pas le tiers
ça n'existe pas ça n'a pas de réalité et
tout ça égare le citoyen alors
je vous dis pas maintenant avec les
communautés de communes les communautés
d'agglomération qui à certains égards
sont positif c'est bien de fédérer des
actions mais vous ne pouvez plus jamais
atteindre le
responsable personne ne sait ce qui se
décide et naturellement la règle
constitutionnelle qui consiste à rendre
compte de l'usage de l'argent public
personne ne peut ne peut l'appliquer ne
peut exiger qu'elle soit
remplie et c'est la même chose je parle
devant les parlementaires européen je je
suis je crois à peu près ce que on peut
faire en France de plus
européen
mais je veux pas qu'il se vexe quand je
dis ça mais personne ne
sait quelles sont les décisions que
l'Union européenne prépare S prêre à
prendre prend personne ne sait quelle
est l'organisation de ces décisions
personne ne sait quels sont les débats
personne n'est capable de désigner les
responsables et personne ne peut
connaître l'agenda de ces décision et on
a donc un découplage je parle devant
celui qui a aimé Versailles qui
ressemble beaucoup au découplage qui
existait entre le peuple des sujets et
puis la cour
enfermé il y a plus de circulation au
Siècle même où l'exigeence d'information
devient la plus importante alors
étonnez-vous des résultats
Italiens les résultats italien qu'est-ce
que c'est
c'est 65 % de la population qui vote
contre la réflexion européenne
l'existence même de
Europe le l'annonce d'un référendum pour
sortir de
l'euro tout ça c'est Grilo plus
Berlusconi plus l'extrême gauche c'est
le même parti
prix et on se trouve avec le pays
fondateur avec nous de l'Union
européenne qui est en contestation
profonde de de ce qu' l'attribue à
l'Europe sans d'ailleurs savoir très
bien comment ça
fonctionne et Monti est un honnête homme
il est d'une certaine manière désigné
ciblé parce que on dit c'est lui qui
exécute la politique défin en Europe tu
parles quand un pays a 130 % de son PIB
en dette imaginz croire que c'est
quelqu'un d'autre qui dicte la nécessité
de faire des économies faut être
complètement
naz et bien c'est cela que nous sommes
en train de vivre et nous sommes en
train de vivre parce que
l'exigence de
compréhensibilité j'invente un mot
le cette exigence là a complètement
disparu alors c'est vrai aussi en
politique culturelle je je frémissais
tout tout à l'heure je dois avoir à peu
près le record du monde du refus de
ministère un jour jacirac m'a proposé de
devenir ministre de la
Culture c'était qu'il voulait se
débarrasser de moi sur d'autres
fonctions je m' presse de le dire parce
que ça serait pas juste
autrement il venait d'être élu et il
s'était mis en tête l'étrange lub de
faire un référendum sur l'éducation
nationale il savait pas bien sur quoi et
il n'imaginait pas comment ça tournerait
mais moi je pense que c'est pas par oui
ou par non que se règle une une si et on
le voit aujourd'hui controversé question
de l'éducation donc il m'a dit je te
nomme ministre de la Culture je dit tu
m'as pas bien regarder si tu me NES
ministre de l'Agriculture j'accepte mais
de la culture ça sera pas moi mais j'ai
vu jackqu langue à la fois ministre de
la culture et de l'éducation alors pour
une fois je serais pas d'accord avec
vous selon moi c'est un ministère
invivable parce que cet ensemble
là éducation culture d'ailleurs je suis
pas persuadé qu'il attachait beaucoup de
soins à cette époque au ministère à la
partie éducation de son ministère mais
euh euh vous êtes dans un monde alors si
vous ajoutez les syndicats de
l'éducation les syndicats du ministère
de la Culture les syndicats des musées
les syndicats des bibliothèques et que
vous mettez en face de tout ça un seul
ministre moi je veux bien qu'on fasse ce
qu'on veut mais celui-là est un surhomme
ou il est mort euh il a pas le il a pas
le choix
euh je comprends très bien l'aspiration
que vous
indiquez là encore le problème du
ministère de la culture c'est que le
citoyen a beaucoup de mal à savoir ce
qu'est l'action du ministère de la
Culture il pressend qu'il y a beaucoup
de réseau au sein du monde de la au sein
du ministère de la Culture beaucoup
d'intérêt qui se défendent et
s'organisent mais il sait pas à quoi
sert le ministère de la Culture et c'est
vrai que cependant il y a eu des choses
très importantes de fait je pense à la
politique du livre si Jack Lang mérite
qu'on lui qu'on lui fasse une place à
part c'est la politique du livre a été
quelque chose de très important et ce
que vous avez fait ensuite sur les
fondations a été aussi quelque chose de
très important bref je veux pas me
laisser entraîner j'ai parlé trop mais
c'était pour indiquer mon adhésion
enthousiaste à une partie de la
réflexion qui était la
vôtre si tu peux faire March ce micro je
sais pas comment on fait pour le faire
marcher
oui je vais vous donner la
parole c'est normal voilà
oui bonsoir Monsieur
aagon donc moi je pense qu'il y a
quelque chose à faire de point de vue de
protection de la culture protection de
des des objets d'art en fait je me
balade assez régulièrement dans les dans
les musées dans les petits musées de de
province dû à mon métier parce que j'ai
plus ou moins un rapport avec le marché
de l'AR je travaille plus ou moins avec
le marché de l'art et et en fait il y a
il y a beaucoup depuis quelques années
des des musées qui sont décentralisé
comme le musée par exemple Centre
Pompidou qui est décentralisé à Metz et
il y a un musée qui a été décentralisé
récemment c'est c'est le musée du Louvre
maintenant il y a ex au musée euh de
lance et en fait ma question elle est
assez simple puisque c'est c'est ça
faisait quelques jours que c'était
ouvert même c'était c'est c'est un un un
fithiver il y a eu je pense ça a été
très très très médiatisé euh il y a une
œuvre d'art de de la croix qui a été euh
qui a étit euh donc je pense qu'il y
aurait quelque chose à faire du point de
vue de la protection des des avres d'art
et et de la sécurité voilà je trouve que
c'est pas normal que plusieurs questions
si vous voulez
bien féminin maintenant
oui allez-y oui bonjour bonsoir plutôt
euh vous parliez d'une bipolarisation
droite gauche est-ce que vous vous
pensez qu'au sein de la politique
culturelle ça se retrouve aussi c'est
est-ce qu'on peut dire qu'il y a une
politique culturelle de droite et une
politique culturelle de
gauche très bien
masculin Gilbert mouton monsieur le
ministre nous connaissons votre amour
pour les animaux vous l'avez d'ailleurs
montré à versaill n'est-ce pas et je
voulais vous poser la question suivante
concernant le ministère de la Culture le
le bureau de la protection animale
appartient au ministère de l'Agriculture
à la Direction Générale de
l'Alimentation euh pas mal de mes
confrères vétérinaires sont partis de ce
bureau pour se rendre justement au
ministère de la Culture ne pensez-vous
pas qu'à la place d'un du bureau de la
protection animale qui en fait n'est que
de la protection sanitaire des animaux
il pourrait se trouver au niveau du
ministère de la Culture une structure un
bureau justement de la protection des
animaux vous voulez dire que il y a des
vétérinaires qui sont partis du
ministère de l'Agriculture pour le
ministère de la Culture tout à fait et
qu'est-ce qu'ils font au ministère de la
Culture il justement de problèmes
d'environnement de problèm de comment
dirais destes des animaux sauvage
justement dans un environnement et la
protection de l'environnement mais c'est
pas le ministère de la Culture si non
parce que l'herbe est pu tendre
culture merci féminin
féminin je travaille dans le domaine du
livre et de la lecture et on peut
remarquer que peut-être on a atteint un
pic avec le gouvernement précédent en ce
qui concerne la vous parliez de
l'information que l'on doit aux citoyens
mais il y a eu sans doute une dérive
avec la visibilité la question de la
visibilité qui hante beaucoup de
ministères et je pense que le le
ministère de la Culture a été frappé
également par cette nécessité de rendre
les choses visibles or il y a sans doute
des actions qui ne sont pas forcément de
l'ordre de la visibilité plus plus
sourde plus profonde et et je pense que
certaines choses se sont développées des
financements pour rendre cette
visibilité possible qui ont sans doute
détourné euh certains certains processus
de de notion de service public à savoir
des institutions comme certains
établissements publics qui se sont
autonomisés et qui ont dû également
rendre visibles leurs activités leurs
actions à tel point que certaines
instances financées par ces mêmes
structures se sont vu déposséd euh
par des activités qui les qui
les tenait en premier lieu donct elles
étaient responsabl qui sont vu
déposséder ces activités parce que le
ministère avait besoin de plus de
visibilité VO je sais pas si c'est un
peu abscon ce que je dis mais je sais à
quoi je pense précisément voilà et et et
nous on n' pas le droit de le
savoir mais je ferm les micro non je
pense au au au Centre national du livre
très précisément et une politique qui
s'est développé de visibilité à à
l'extrême euh et et une institution je
se trouve que je dirige une structure
qui est financé par le Ministère de la
Culture et menacé dans ses actions mêmes
parce que le on arrive à marcher sur la
tête c'est que le ministère organise
lui-même des des événements parlons
d'événement l'événem cel alors queil
finance des structures qui sont faites
pour organiser pour lui voilà on a un
peu marché sur la tête à ce moment-là
c'est une remarque quelle question voilà
écoutez ce sont des questions très très
diverses d'abord monsieur euh bon vous
avez bien fait de rappeler que euh la
décentralisation des grands
établissements nationaux inaugurés par
le Centre pompiloues et ensuite par le
louvrelance c'est tout à fait
fondamental pour ma part j'ai toujours
pensé qu'il fallait faire en sorte que
les établissements nationaux ne soient
pas uniquement des établissements
parisiens en France on a trop souvent
confondu on a trop souvent cru que
national ça voulait dire parisien
national ça veut dire que ça appartient
la Nation toute entière et je pense que
ces grosses machines que sont le musée
national du Louvre le musée national
d'art moderne le musée d'Orsay l'opéra
nationale de Paris la Bibliothèque
nationale de France ont le devoir de
s'interroger à chaque moment sur la
façon de se rendre utile aux citoyens de
notre pays tout entier d' le caractère
exemplaire de ces deux actions de
décentralisation elles ont connu l'une
et l'autre un succès immense rassemblant
au cours de leur première année
d'ouverture sans doute puisque la
première année d'ouverture pour le
louvreelance n'est pas encore totalement
ement conclu mais en tout cas plus d'un
million de visiteurs alors lorsqu'on
reçoit un million de visiteurs il se
peut qu'il se produise un moment un
petit incident dans un public
enthousiaste il y a toujours dans la
masse des centaines de milliers de gens
qui se présent dans un musée quelqu'un
qui est un peu exalté et qui se livre à
un acte de dégradation d'une œuvre c'est
regrettable mais c'est en quelque sorte
la rançon de cet immense succès en
l'occurrence d'ailleurs cette
dégradation été mineure elle a été
réparée très très rapidement
elle était réparée très rapidement par
de bons par de bons restaurateurs et
surtout les responsables du musée les
collectivité local concerné en
l'occurrence la région Nord patcalé sont
aussitôt demandé de quelle façon on
pouvait intensifier la présence de
médiateur ou d'agent parmi ces œuvres de
façon à éviter ce type de ce type de de
ce type de dégradation ENF en tout cas
je le répète saz un musée vide c'est un
musée triste alors naturellement les
œuvres n'y risque rien du tout mais en
même temps la mission culturelle de ces
musées n'est pas atteinte une œuvre qui
n'a plus de regard pour la contempler
devient un objet totalement mort alors
la contrepartie du succès c'est parfois
en effet c'est le risque mais il n'y a
pas de politique sans risque il faut
parfois assumer ses risques madame sur
la question de savoir s'il existe une
politique de droite sur une politique de
gauche je crois qu'en toute objectivité
il faut dire qu'il y a eu au cours des
dernières décennies il y a eu une très
grande stabilité finalement en France
des euh des des politiques
culturelles les ministres de droite
sentant en général ilégitime au ministre
de la Culture finissant par faire les
mêmes politiques que leurs prédécesseurs
les assumant et donc finalement l'un
dans l'autre c'est plutôt un ministre un
ministère de consensus avec parfois des
nuances néanmoins dans l'approche des
choses on a souvent pensé que la droite
était plus attentive à l'égard la
dimension patrimoniale de ce ministère
que la gauche était plus tournée vers
l'action vers la action culturelle
encore qu'il ne fallait pas caricaturer
ses prises de position voilà en
succédant à Catherine taskaa je je sais
bien que j'ai fait les choses
différemment qu'elle les auraiit pas
fait comme moi mais l'un dans l'autre
quand même je pense que ce sont les
mêmes politiques qui se sont poursuivi
en plus ce ministère a été frappé par
une très grave maladie quand même c'est
la précarité de ses ministres quand je
suis arrivé au ministère de la Culture
j'étais le 7e ministre de la décennie je
l'ai quitté ce ministère il y a il y a
il y a 10 ans ou presque 10 ans il y a 9
ans maintenant et j'ai déjà eu comme
successeur donc il y a eu moi il y a eu
Renault die Vabre il y a eu Christine
Albanel il y a eu Frédéric mitteran il y
a Aurélie Philipp aujourd'hui donc vous
voyez cinq ministres pour occuper
l'espace de 10 ans ça fait que
finalement très souvent on poursuit les
actions mises en œuvre par son
prédécesseur et que ce sont vos vos
successeurs qui finalement inaugureront
ce que vous avez mis ce que vous avez
vous-même mis en re j'ai mis en œuvre le
Centre des Archives nationales à
pierrefit avec l'appui de Jacques Chirac
c'est aujourd'hui aéie philippetti et
François Hollande qui les inaugure j'ai
lancé le centre pompidoues il a été
inauguré par il a été inauguré par
Frédéric mitteran j'ai lancé le
louvrelance il a été inauguré par je ne
sais même plus qui d'ailleurs tant
lesévanaissence ministérielle et et
grand donc plutôt c'est vraiment une
politique sur laquelle il faudrait
d'ailleurs qu'on définisse des objectifs
de de convergence de convergence
nationale et qu'on prennent en compte
l'intérêt général et non pas euh et non
pas euh les intérêts partisans de tel ou
tel de tel ou telle partie de de
l'opinion publique alors madame sur la
question de euh la super du risque de
superficialité c'est vrai que ce
ministère peut être tenté étant tenté
par une attitude permanente de
communication euh peut privilégier
parfois ce qui a de l'éclat de la
visibilité euh et donc qui est éphémère
par par rapport à ce qui est profond ce
qui est radicalement enraciné dans
l'émission de de service public vous
avez évoqué la question du livre la
question de la lecture publique pour ma
part j'estime qu'on est là dans l' un
des fondamentaux de l'action de ce de ce
ministère qu' n'y a pas d'espace plus
noble finalement après l'école monsieur
le ministre d'acculturation de nos
concitoyens et partage la culture que
les bibliothèques que que le livre alors
c'est vrai qu'on voit parfois le
ministère pr ou les collectivités
locales d'ailleurs les collectivités
sont ne sont pas épargnées toujours par
cette par cette par ce glissement par ce
par cette véritable maladie qui consiste
à préférer ce qui est vain ce qui est
superficiel ce qui est festive ce qui
est ludique ce qui est éphémère par
rapport à ce qui est moins spectaculaire
mais pourtant beaucoup plus nécessaire
quant à l'autonomisation des
établissements publics je crois que
c'est une bonne règle hein il faut que
l'État apprenne à ne pas tout vouloir
tout faire lui-même de son depuis son
administration centrale il faut qu'il
sache déléguer à à des établissements
qu'elle confie des responsabilités leur
déléguer le soin de mettre en œuvre
dépend de sa politique dépend de la
politique culturelle regarder ce que le
Louvre est devenu en sa qualité
d'établissement public que le Centre
Pompidou a été d sa sa dè sa création on
n'est jamais aussi autant porteur d'un
projet culturel que lorsqu'on a la
véritable responsabilité de le mettre en
œuvre et il appartient ensuite à la
puissance publique de vous juger à la
sortie de dire vous avez été un bon
président ou un mauvais Président je
vous reconduis ou finalement je vous
remplace je vous donne des moyens ou je
je vous en donne moin l'État doit
conserver ses moyens d'évaluation mais
en même temps il doit savoir déléguer de
la responsabilité professeur euh vous
savez mon amour pour les animaux donc
j'ai beaucoup de mal à répondre à votre
question de façon de façon partisane né
en moins je je ne suis pas sûr euh la
question la question de notre relation
avec les animaux est une question euh
est une question culturelle c'est pas
c'est une question qu'on peut pas
expulser du champ de la culture
récemment c'était il y a 15 jours me
trouvant dans le petit musée d'Och dans
le département du Gers j'ai découvert
euh j'en ai d'ailleurs fait une
photographie avec mon téléphone une
plaque tombale une dédicace d'une domina
donc d'une maîtresse romaine du 2e ou du
3e siècle et puis qui recouvrait la la
tombe de sa petite de sa petite chienne
qui s'appelait Mia et donc il y a là une
véritable
élégie consacré au souvenirs de Mya
c'est un acte c'est un acte culturel que
cette relation l'animal est un vieux
compagnon de l'homme il accompagne la
domestication des animaux accompagne
l'émergence de l'humanité hein comme
espèce comme espèce vivante supérieure
dominant justement l'ordre naturel
sommaire euh des choses mais je ne suis
pas sûr quit à vous décevoir qu'on
trouve au ministère de la Culture
aujourd'hui toutes les compétences
requises pour fournir au vétérinaire un
interlocuteur mieux désigné comme
ministère de comme ministère de
l'agriculture c'est vrai que le
ministère l'agriculture a trop souvent
peut-être une approche uniquement
sanitaire euh de la question du
finalement de la du du du statut du
statut des des animaux qui renvoie
d'ailleurs également à des questions de
droit dont la chance cellerie s'occupe
mais voilà alors sinon il faudrait et là
pour le coup François Baayou serait
totalement désespéré faire un ministère
de la Culture de l'agriculture de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse des
sport voà et ça s'appellerait la
présidence de la République
mais merci beaucoup je dois dire
monsieur que quand je vous ai entendu
commencer votre question en disant
monsieur le ministre tout le monde
connaît votre amour des animaux je ne
savais pas si c'était à Jacques que
s'adressait cette cette formule ou à moi
mais je vous assure que comme amour des
animaux nous pouvons rivaliser ou en
tout cas lier nos forces je vais prendre
les deux dernières
questions une masculine une féminine
parce qu'il est bientôt 8h25 oui bonjour
monsieur je travaille depuis 2007 avec
Fred Forest et qui m'a fait découvrir la
la culturation du du numérique par la
culture et et que pensez-vous de
l'appropriation du numérique par la
culture et de du rôle que va pouvoir
jouer la culture dans le futur du 21e
siècle qui et le développement de la
émocratie Merci une une question
féminine pour
finir féminine
oui
bonsoir j'aimerais poser une question un
peu plus personnelle personnelle euh
c'est sur Versailles je sais que vous
étiez beaucoup critiqué euh par rapport
au choix que vous avez fait avec l'art
contemporain à Versailles j'aimerais
savoir qu'est-ce que vous pensez de tout
ça voilà madame écoutez tout d'abord sur
sur sur sur Versailles vous saz j'ai
toujours eu la conviction et c'est pour
moi une conviction très très profonde
qu'il fallait mettre fin à cette
frontière absolue qu'on dresse entre
l'art contemporain et l'art ancien l'art
contemporain à mes yeux n'existe pas
c'est une réalité contemp éphémère que
d'être contemporain tout ce qui est
contemporain deviendra deviendra
historique le l'impressionnisme à M
donné a été une expression contemporaine
de l'art et puis il est devenu un
morceau de notre histoire de notre
histoire artistique donc l'art qui se
produit aujourd'hui est certes
contemporain au sens exact du terme mais
le meilleur de la production artistique
d'aujourd'hui a des relations avec la
production artistique d'hier les
meilleurs des artistes ont des racines
et les meilleurs d'entre eux auront une
une une postérité il faut cesser de
considérer que l'art contemporain serait
une sorte de de destination artistique
en soi qu'elle n'aurait pas de veille et
qu'elle n'aurait pas de lendemain
qu'elle serait une sorte d'éphémère
permanent à versaill ce que j'ai tenté
de montrer c'est que dans ce lieu qui
n'a jamais été un carmel c'est pas un
lieu de dévolution versaill c'est un
lieu qui a été conçu pour la fête pour
le divertissement au point d'ailleurs
d'en devenir superficiel et de susciter
des phénomènes d'hostilité très fort au
moment de la Révolution française que
dans ce lieu on s'est toujours posé un
certain nombre de questions la question
du décoratif la question du décor la
question de la fête la question de y
compris la question du plaisir euh la
question euh la question
euh de la présence internationale euh
d'artistes c'est le l X qui fait venir
Bernin euh de façon d'ailleurs
inaccomplie à Versailles pour tenter euh
de travailler avec lui et que toutes ces
questions que ce bâtiment que les
jardins euh que ces décors avaient posés
il fallait également les reposer
aujourd'hui avec des propositions euh
artistiques contemporaines alors ça
suscitait parfois l'incompréhension ça
suscité de l'émotion mais ça a suscité
également un énorme un immense
engouement populaire puisque la
fréquentation du château de versail s'en
est trouvé considérablement accru ça m'a
valu quelques procès à chaque fois euh
je les ai tous gagné euh et donc je suis
toujours parmi vous on ne m'a pas coupé
la tête un de ces procès m'a tout
particulièrement ennuyé c'était le
premier qu'on m'avait fait au moment de
l'exposition Jeff kons tout simplement
parce que le jugement était rendu le 24
décembre au soir et que ça a gâché mon
dîner euh mon dîner et ma soirée de de
Noël mais néanmoins je l'ai emporté je
l'ai emporté contre un personnage
éminent puisqu'il s'agissait d'un prince
de la maison de Bourbon Bourbon Parme
qui en effet se plaignit au tribunal de
mon manque de respect pour la mémoire de
ses aïeux donc le juge a compris que
j'étais extrêmement respectueux à
l'égard de la mémoire de Lou XIV et
quand même d'une certaine façon
j'incarner la pérenité de ce qu'avait
été son goût pour la fête son goût pour
les arts son goût également pour la pour
la pour la création pour ce qui est
Monsieur de de l' culture de la culture
numérique je considère que bon d'une
part il est évident que la
numérisation des œuvres que la
numérisation des informations que leur
diffusion par ce canal universel qui est
internet constitue pour la chance pour
la culture et pour le partage de la
culture une chance une chance
extraordinaire hein je crois que jamais
euh on aura euh pu mettre à la
disposition euh des des gens de façon
générale autant de références autant
d'images euh autant euh d'accès euh
diversifié à la culture alors la
question qui se pose c'est naturellement
la question de l'émergence d'un
véritable jugement critique à le à
l'égard euh dans dans dans l'usage de
cette abondance d'information de façon à
ce que celui euh qui les sollicite
puisse arbitrer entre celles qui sont
fondées celles qui sont de qualité
celles qui sont de moindre qualité et
même celles qui sont parfois totalement
farfelu ou mensongère c'est la raison
pour laquelle il faut sans doute que
mais je crois que ça se fait assez
spontanément dans les programmes de
l'Éducation on sache finalement exercer
euh les jeunes et les moins jeunes
d'ailleurs à l'usage critique à l'usage
raisonné des technologies de
l'information de la communication et de
l'accès qu'elle permett à la culture et
au savoir alors d'autre part vous le
savez aussi votre question y renvoie
directement il est évident que cette
technologie permett également à des
artistes de s'exprimer autrement de
s'exprimer par d'autres voix et parfois
de façon extrêmement extrêmement
extrêmement pertinente de façon
extrêmement innovante il y a là un
nouveau champ pour l'expression
artistique dans le domaine des arts
plastiques mais également dans d'autres
domaines dans le domaine de l'oralité
dans le domaine de la littérature et
dans le domaine de la musique en tout
cas je je je je considère que tout cela
que cette révolution
technologique aussi importante si ce
n'est plus importante que l'invention de
l'imprimerie à la fin du 15e siècle est
une véritable chance pour la culture il
faut pas regarder cet avenir avec
frilosité alors je sais bien que les
copistes la fin du 15e siècle
s'inquiéter de de l'extinction de leur
activité euh face à l'émergence de celle
des imprimeurs mais c'est néanmoins de
cette effflorescence de l'imprimerie que
sont né la réforme et et qui est né
l'épanouissement complet de la
Renaissance et d'une certaine façon
également l'affirmation de l'esprit
critique dans l'espace européen cette
grande caractéristique de notre de notre
culture merci à jeanjac à vous d'avoir
été là pour ce moment de rencontre
passionnant merci à tous merci monsieur
le
président